a irmã de joão seduz muito diferentes
não vai dar certo
alguns convênios que a gente tinha no
começo do projeto do projeto com o dia
do livro dessa cor lápis pensou um pouco
de uma risada ea gente começou a brincar
com as três cores de velho de tudo o
amarelo marrom vermelho etc
aí já era só desejo o comandante
comentou
a gente fez um dia achar outras escolas
um projeto parecido com o nosso
oi tudo bem ela não falar e tal do bené
fala que tá lá estamos aqui para fazer
um convite nem é esse que você sente a
gente queria contar um pouquinho quem
são eo que fazem
neste vídeo você vai conhecer a empresa
jovem e durante fogo nesse grupo de
jovens da cidade de são paulo de escolas
diferentes que gostam de silêncio screen
olha só que legal muito prazer são
somente em copa do brasil somos a
imprensa jovem mas o que fazem esses
jogos
a igreja jovem é um programa criado em
2005 pela secretaria municipal de
educação de são paulo - á net casa
blanca as aulas começarem em 2013 com o
foco no projeto no fundo vazio além de
foco é uma oficina de comunicação do
colégio dante alighieri e nós somos
considerados a imprensa oficial dos
eventos da escola alcina já tem nove
anos e foi criada a pedido de dois
alunos o nosso colégio utilizando
diferentes linguagens fotografamos
escrevemos entrevistamos gravamos
fazendo trabalho de rádio e de
apresentações e cobertura de eventos
culturais
também produzimos legendas em farsi
colaborativo nós temos adiante que
funciona desde o empregado também
fazendo entrevistas para tv durante as
últimas notícias mais importantes da
semana e inscrevemos para o blog do
jornal o estado de são paulo além disso
quando os eventos dentro e fora do
colégio anos em nosso grupo os jovens de
diferentes idades o que é muito bom
trocamos idéias somos um grupo alegre
com muita colaboração
trabalhamos muito mas nos divertimos
também integrava erra gravar de novo mas
afinal ela te que importa mas o que
estamos dizendo porque fazemos parte de
um projeto de educomunicação nós foi um
pouquinho que já vamos falar do ano
durante esses encontros conversamos
muito e descobrimos o que cada um
produza em sua escola descobriu que o
ambiente um pouco sobre isso a jovem
fazer atividades muito conhecidos fazem
13 para rádio com cobertura de eventos e
atividades professores mar
a fazer o sixx am da usp conhecer os
dois grupos nos aproximar
valeu conversar é o nosso mundo com
tópicos anos no vídeo conferência
contando quem somos do que gostamos
ao longo do projeto fomos encontrando e
pensando juntos em que mundo vivemos em
qual queremos viver
nós nos lugares por sua vez no mundo em
que vivemos muito na imprensa jovem ao
muito se comunicar de repetir e de
propor mudanças você deixa o foco do
olhar crítico queremos mostrar outras
possibilidades para as pessoas só
havendo débito mas não dessa sociedade
que nós - queremos sugerir a naspers
níveis mais altos de leitura que
queremos produzir conteúdo e fazer novos
amigos que projeto é esse que uniu duas
escolas regiões em realidades tão
diferentes na cidade de são paulo
promove inscrita em dois grupos que
gostam de rádio e tv e de análise de
mídia os nosso interesses envolvem
educomunicação juntando a educação com a
comunicação
decidimos nos unir em um projeto que
gostaria de mudar o mundo utilizando é
claro os meios de comunicação e como
fazer isso
queremos inspirar as pessoas hashtag
aberta a todos
gastei por um mundo melhor e assim
entender que mudam só as realidades tão
distintas mas é possível conviver em paz
nós aprendemos mais quando escutamos o
astro ainda sem o sentimento de amizade
e companheirismo
mostramos uma equipe que se gosta e
respeita as diferenças e achamos que
podemos melhorar o mundo por meio da
união que combate preconceitos e
injustiças
então aceitar tudo diga sim por um mundo
melhor que está fazendo um projeto assim
na sua escola
deixe por medalha da comunicação e gente
baixo os outros jovens a darem as mãos
em diferentes escolas
sim é possível aprender no sul com os
outros maneiras diferentes de fazer
aquilo que gostamos é possível fazer
diferente é feg aceita tudo por um mundo
melhor
e é por isso que a gente está aqui nesse
vídeo falando com você mas espera um
pouco esse projeto acaba aqui não passa
você também quem disse que a iniciativa
não pode ser sua
quem disse que uma pequena idéia não
pode se tornar algo muito maior
somos jovens são as escolas
a sua a escola também pode posso a você
também faz a integração
há muitos por cento do nosso mundo
esperando para felipe e jeff beck
diferente na sua playboy fez outras
escolas face aos amigos tudo também é
que comunica que você também podemos sim
usar os meios de comunicação para
prender um conjunto é assim mudar a
questão uma senhora que eu faça você
também
quem não se ativo e tem grande todo
mundo diferente mas sempre alguma coisa
precisa é muito que aprender sabe você
também só poderá usar o mundo com um
diálogo então converse conheça nossa
você também em você gostou da ideia
começa muito melhores diretores para
fazer algo que ajude a mudar meus olhos
seu redor desculpe o amigo do outro
escreve um vídeo para fazer parte desse
movimento
hoje ele já estar a produzir para pensar
para o vírus para ser o vídeo a costura
e principalmente para transformar nossa
você também que é tão várias amigas para
melhorar o mundo
hashtags em que todos querem por um
mundo melhor
então aceita todos por um mundo melhor
apesar de tentar sócios dia né
agora é a vez de vocês e aí eu vi que
você ainda não conhece
olha acho legal as mesmas séries de
julgar essa pessoa nem está em todo
lugar
[Aplausos]
[Música]